ich habe mich wirklich darauf
vorbereitet mehrlagig okay und dann
fährt auch auf mehr lage ich wie immer
und auch gut so das heißt mehr lag ich
wieviel lang gibt es bei dir drei
mindestens okay also wie bei standard
klopapier gibt kein einmaliges cooper p3
lage ich gut schlecht normal bin jetzt
gerade hier ich bin ein bisschen
aufgeregt ich find's lustig auf jeden
fall
und so geht es mir gerade das ist meine
dass die lage von mir warum liebst du
aufgeregt du bist doch ständig vor der
kamera ich war ja das kommt immer ganz
darauf an also wir haben uns vor zwei
jahren drei an 23 jahren irgendwie kurz
getroffen
das genaue alter das ist schon uralt auf
jeden fall und da habe ich aber gemerkt
okay du gehst anders an die interviews
trainer in der zeit hast du sehr viele
andere interviews gemacht mit leuten die
ich interessant finde und ich habe
gemerkt wie dein interview stil ist und
der ist schon der ist sehr direkt auf
jeden fall machen vergleich zur bild der
ist aber nicht negativ gemacht
du schaffst automatisch halt
überschriften so funktioniert das ja und
du weißt wie es funktioniert das ist
deswegen habe ich angst deswegen
deswegen eigentlich redet viel schneller
aber ich denke gleichzeitig nach
ich bin immer noch ich bin daran gewöhnt
dass kameras da sind ja ich habe das
irgendwie mitbekommen und gelernt aber
ich fühle mich nicht unbedingt wohl ich
guck mich auch selber sehr ungern an
so habe ich dir schon eine frage
weggenommen in größeren schritten voran
warum ist es dann weiß ich nicht es gibt
viele möglichkeiten es macht ja auch
spaß man lernt lustige leute kennen und
es hört sich immer so kitschig an aber
themen sind mir wichtig ich finde es
unfassbar schön wenn man sich selbst ein
thema zurechtlegt recherchiert und guckt
okay was fasziniert mich an einem thema
was interessiert mich ein thema wie kann
ich das einmal sozusagen komplett
auseinanderbauen und wie kann ich sein
eigenes wort mit meiner eigenen meinung
noch mal neu zusammenpacken und wie
schaffst du es dann bestenfalls auch
noch andere leute nicht zu überzeugen
aber ihnen
argumentativ deine sichtweise zu
erklären bestenfalls dabei zu
unterhalten bestenfalls dabei
informationen rüberzubringen wie auch
immer das mag ich mag ich sehr gerne und
dadurch dass ich kein so guter schreiber
bin kein guter kamera bin kameramann bin
etc ich bin da halt voll kamera
reingewachsen
und das ermöglicht mir viele
möglichkeiten deswegen mache ich es
tatsächlich und es macht auch spaß keine
frage aber das ist mit all den jahren
irgendwie ich bin inzwischen seit wann
22 knapp zehn jahren bin ich irgendwie
vor der kamera unterwegs und man lernt
er doch schon einige sachen und wenn man
dann immer mehr dazulernen und weiß okay
wenn ich die kamera so positionieren
wenn ich das im schnittprogramm so mache
wenn ich die tags wie auch immer so und
zu vorbereitet dann hat man sehr lustige
kreative möglichkeiten zum beispiel dass
da noch zu steuern so also inszenierung
nicht dass hier finde ich manchmal ein
bisschen gruselig weil ich habe da keine
kontrolle darüber will ich aber auch
nicht haben in dem modell kleine also
das ist so angst ist vielleicht auch das
falsche wort respekt vielleicht auch
länger so aber wenn ich jetzt weiß okay
du bist du besuch christoph du bist hier
vom simon studio und ich baue mindset
auf dann würde ich da wahrscheinlich
eher an text denken weil ich dann weiß
okay ich werde dann öl wie die infos
anders verpacken das ist dann ein
anderer stil aber ich habe dann in der
post hat mehr kontrolle darüber
aber so wie es ist wobei wenn
todlangweilig ist aber das ist selten
der fall scheint auch mal was raus ist
ja dass man ist todlangweilig ist
deswegen sind so viele kameras aufgebaut
wir machen ja jetzt eine aber da sieht
man auch die schnitte highlight version
aber fürchte dich da manchmal zerrissen
zwischen hört sich ein bisschen an
zwischen hinter und vor der kamera
stehen der die ganze hatten damit nervig
glaube ich auch alle alle
arbeitskollegen und alle freunde stetig
das wechselt bei mir mal hab ich
tierisch bock drauf und nun mal habe ich
nicht so viel bock drauf und ich sage
eigentlich seit jahren eigentlich möchte
ich oft eher gehen und es war bei 7 und
mir auch ganz am anfang
von gamern so dass wir das konzept
geschrieben haben und da haben wir sehr
viel spaß dran
generell an der kreativen leistung aber
auch thema zuerst und und dann gucken
wir was danach kommt und wir hatten uns
gar nicht primär selber in das format
reingeschrieben so wir wollten auf jeden
fall eine doppelmoderation haben wir
wollen auf jeden fall zwei leute haben
die das thema gut rüberbringen
aber wer uns da nicht namentlich rein
geschrieben das war nicht so wichtig das
ist einfach so und das ist wirklich cool
unterschiedlich jetzt gerade fühle ich
mich wohl vor der kamera heute morgen
habe ich noch gedacht nee ich irgendwie
ich weiß ich nicht mal gucken wie das
wird und das wechselt stetig es kommt
aber dann auch immer auf die arbeit
darauf an also so wie das halt ich
glaube jedem ist manchmal wechselt der
geschmack manchmal wechselt der stil
manchmal wechselt so ein bisschen die
emotionen und die so wie es einem geht
und dann hat man mal mehr bock
kostümiert angemalt vor die kamera zu
gehen um mit dem gewissen dass gleich
einem per post der kopf explodieren wird
oder nicht
aber das ist ist es eine tolle zeit die
wir jetzt haben wo man selber ohne einen
fernsehsender programm machen kann auf
youtube oder ist es eine furchtbare zeit
weil man durch e-mail twitter facebook
what's up
foursquare ich meine wo man alles über
aktiv ist reagiert
keine ahnung ist es zuviel müssen wir
uns alle in schnellen damit wir nicht so
generationen depressionen dann
irgendwann mal aufschließen
ich glaube da gibt es kein allheilmittel
soll es auch nicht geben also das ding
ist so dass das passiert und es hat sich
eine unfassbare dynamik entwickelt warum
wir nicht drüber zu reden auch die leute
sitzen zu hause und netz oder an ihrem
smartphone und gucken sich hoffentlich
dieses video an so und wenn ich dann ist
es auch okay also das ist so
die möglichkeiten sind unfassbar da
draußen und ich glaub nicht ich sage
nicht dass man sich jetzt grundlegend
schnell soll das muss jeder für sich
entscheiden
ich glaube schon dass es durchaus sinn
macht mal darüber nachzudenken um eine
gewisse perspektive
wenig zu verlieren das ist eine andere
perspektive das ist nicht nur input
einnehmen sondern auch mal eigenen input
kreieren und den dann heraus zu geben
weil wenn du nur konsumiert verliert
sich glaube ich meiner meinung nach
irgendwann der eigene also die eigene
subjektivität na ja also das ist das ist
ein bisschen bei mir so der punkt wenn
man sich schnell das wort ist eigentlich
ganz nett
dann hast du mehr zeit zu reflektieren
und mehr zeit argument für dieselbe zu
suchen das finde ich gut weil wenn
aktuell twitter bestes beispiel disney
kauft lucasarts auf meeres films es ist
lustig ist es unglaublich lustig eine
komplette timelines eu wahl freuen mit
sehr lustigen wortspielen mit wirklich
hasstiraden mit ängsten und
befürchtungen teile 798 ja ich bin
gespannt aber dass mainz über fürchten
aber dass man in serie
ich habe sehr viel darüber gelesen aber
wenn ich jetzt mal zurücklehnen und
überlege okay was ist dann meine meinung
wenn ich nur die nachricht bekommen und
hätte das alles nicht gelesen
jetzt bin ich schon vor geprägt so ich
habe es nicht gelesen das ist deine
meinung ich kann meine meinung sage
meine meinung ist vor geprägt von dem
was ich bin tatsächlich da bin ich ein
bisschen da ziehe ich mich aus affäre
ich sage halt einfach ich fand 13 auch
wirklich wirklich nicht gut
ich weiß dass fünf und sechs die alten
star wars filme eine komplette kindliche
verklärt hat in sich tragen aber ich sie
natürlich großartig finde
und ich sage ich bin vollkommen gespannt
was sie mit 789 machen